Les enfants ont des questions.
Les parents ont "Dis Jamy Kid's",
mon nouveau podcast
qui répond aux questions des enfants.
Disponible seulement sur Deezer.
Si je vous dis le roi des fruits ?
Vous me répondez :
la pomme. De fait,
c'est le fruit le plus consommé
en France, devant la banane et l'orange.
Mais si je vous dis le fruit préféré
des rois ? Réponse :
la poire ! Ce fruit a plein
de choses étonnantes à nous raconter.
Je me suis longtemps
demandé s'il fallait parler
du fruit ou des recettes
qui sont élaborées à partir du fruit.
Et finalement, j'ai coupé
la poire en deux.
Ce sera un peu des deux. Suivez-moi.
La poire vient de Chine, où elle était
déjà cultivée il y a près de 6000 ans.
Elle a ensuite progressivement gagné
l'Europe, où la culture des poiriers
est attestée depuis au moins deux mille
quatre cents ans.
Ainsi, aujourd'hui, on classe
toutes les variétés de poire en deux
grandes catégories : les poires asiatiques
et les poires européennes.
Les premières comme celle-ci,
une Nashi qui vient de Chine,
sont issues des descendants
des premiers poiriers sauvages
et ont une chair plutôt croquante,
un peu comme celle des pommes.
D'ailleurs, celle-ci ressemble
à une pomme. Les secondes,
les poires européennes viennent
quant à elles d'une même espèce,
le poirier commun de son petit nom
Pyrus communis.
La chair est tendre et juteuse.
Alors une poire, c'est d'abord
un régal pour les yeux.
Ça va du jaune de la Guyot
à la Wiliam rouge,
en passant par le vert tendre de l’Abate,
le bronze de la Général Leclerc
ou encore le vert bronze de la conférence.
Au passage, cette dernière doit
son nom au prix qu'elle a remporté
à la Conférence nationale
britannique de la poire en 1885.
Il y a à poire et à manger,
comme on dit. Pas mal.
Toutes ces variétés présentent autant
de différences, de texture et de saveur.
Chacune a son identité de goût.
Née des sélections faites depuis des centaines d'années et encore très récemment.
La dernière en date
s'appelle Angys ou Angélys.
A l'époque de son inscription
au catalogue des variétés en 1998.
Elle est née dans les vergers
des chercheurs de l'INRAE,
l'Institut National de Recherche
pour l'Agriculture et l'Environnement.
D'un croisement entre la doyenné du Comice
et la doyenné d'hiver.
Enfin, un croisement... Façon de parler.
Les chercheurs ont mélangé
douze variétés de poires
et fait pousser 11 000 poiriers
avant de la sélectionner.
Son nom combine le
lieu de sa naissance Angers
avec le lys, l'emblème des rois de France.
On dit que la poire était le fruit préféré
des rois
de Louis XIV en particulier.
Il n'aimait pas seulement son goût.
Il adorait aussi sa texture. Normal,
à la fin de sa vie,
le Roi Soleil n'avait plus de dents.
Et comme à l'époque,
il n'y avait pas de couronne.
Enfin, je veux dire,
pour cacher la misère dans sa bouche,
le Roi se les était toutes faites arracher
et devait se débrouiller sans.
Dans ces conditions, vous en conviendrez,
il était plus facile
de croquer une poire
qu'une pomme ou une noix.
Par ailleurs, les poires ont l'avantage
de pousser presque toute l'année,
ce qui donnait à Louis XIV
de bonnes raisons pour apprécier ce fruit.
Il y a les poires
d'été comme la Guyot,
la Wiliam qui existe aussi en jaune,
et les poires d'automne
et d'hiver telles que la Beurré
Hardy, l’Alexandrine,
la Comice, la Passe-Crassane.
Celles d'été doivent se récolter
mûres et se déguster rapidement.
Si vous tombez sur
un poirier plein de poires
et que vous avez le droit de vous servir,
saisissez-en une tournée là
d'un quart de tour.
Si elle se détache de l'arbre,
c'est qu'elle est mûre. Sur les étals,
la poire d'été doit être souple
autour du pédoncule
et celui-ci doit être bien
attaché au fruit.
Les variétés d'automne et d'hiver
se récoltent à partir de mi-septembre,
alors qu'elles ne sont pas encore mûres.
Après un passage au froid obligatoire
pour qu'elles puissent
poursuivre leurs maturation,
elles arrivent sur les étals.
Il faut alors les choisir bien fermes,
car elles continuent à mûrir.
Finalement, en France,
en alternant les variétés,
on peut déguster
des poires du mois de juillet
au mois de mai suivant
et donc les cuisiner à toutes les sauces.
Ça, ça sent la cuisine.
On peut bien sûr croquer la poire nature
au dessert ou au goûter,
ou préférez une compote de poire,
du jus de poire,
des poires au sirop ou même
une tarte aux poires.
Personnellement, j'hésite un peu.
Il y a aussi la fameuse poire
Belle-Hélène, créée sans doute en 1864,
au moment de la sortie de l'opéra bouffe
La Belle Hélène.
Ce dessert consiste à éplucher une poire
en conservant son pédoncule,
à la pocher, c'est à dire la cuire
dans un mélange de sucre et d'eau,
puis à la napper de chocolat chaud
et à la servir accompagnée
d'une glace à la vanille.
Il y a aussi les poires tapées,
vous connaissez ?
C'est une recette de Touraine,
dans la région d'Azay
le Rideau, célèbre pour son château.
Cette tradition des poires tapées
remonte au Moyen-Âge, au XI siècle.
Elle permet de conserver les fruits longtemps
en les desséchant.
Les poires sont épluchées, rangées
dans des caissettes grillagées,
puis enfournées plusieurs jours
dans un four à bois.
Elles se déshydratent, puis sont aplaties
avec une sorte de presse.
Les poires tapées peuvent
alors se déguster telles quelles.
Ou alors réhydratées dans un sirop
ou du vin de Loire, par exemple.
Je m'en taperai bien une.
Et vous, quelle est votre recette préférée ?
Dites-le-moi en commentaire.
Allez, raconte-nous
encore de “belles his-poires”.
Je vois que le prince
des mots tordus est passé par là.
La poire a donné son nom à un instrument
utilisé en médecine
pour le nettoyage des oreilles,
par exemple, Daumier,
le célèbre illustrateur du 19e siècle, l'a
utilisé pour caricaturer Louis-Philippe.
Et puis, à la fin des années 1970 début
des années 1980, elle a aussi inspiré
des publicitaires pour faire la promotion
d'un modèle de voiture, la Renault 14.
J'en ai conduit une, une fois.
Elle avait la pêche. J'ai arrêté, j'avais peur de me prendre une prune.
C'est aussi le nom d'une
figure de gymnastique.
Pas la poire directement, mais l'arbre
sur lequel elle pousse : le poirier.
Je préfère faire le poireau.
Je savais bien qu'on allait finir
par se fendre la poire, allez à bientôt
les épicurieux et les épicurieuses.
Et si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
une Nashi qui vient de Chine ah dommage...
Toutes ces variétés présentent
autant de textu... Je reprends.